foreign
[Music]
should your money be going to fund this
sort of Trade union for Northern
conservative MPS and should public money
be funding groups whose leaders do this
coup is when you use illegitimate
procedures to try and overturn somebody
who is in office who is the wrong word
[Music]
how taxpayers cash moves around
Westminster isn't always obvious and
what do MPS get for spending your money
there's no connection between your
membership and receiving political
donations
Sky News Westminster accounts
investigation is following the money
through every part of our political
system
almost everyone knows the price of an
MP's salary nearly 90 000 pounds paid by
public money
what's less widely known is a much
bigger sum around a quarter of a million
pounds is given to MPS each year to fund
their office travel buildings and staff
and political research each MP can
choose to subscribe to research groups
using your money and looking at those
accounts sounds straightforward but can
take you to some unexpected places
this is the leaderboard of how much
public money MPS have diverted to
support their political campaigns names
of bodies you almost certainly won't
recognize but accounting for a huge
amount of taxpayers cash 6.8 million
pounds of public money in just this
Parliament alone from December 2019
until the start of this year so where's
that money going these groups with the
extremely Monday names are Central party
research groups each major party has one
at the top is the Parliamentary Research
Unit conservative MPS have given it over
three million pounds in public money to
fund research which every Tory MP can
then use it's been going on for years
and is relatively uncontroversial these
groups are different they are factions
within the conservative and labor
parties and they've been receiving a lot
of public cash to support their
campaigning in the last two years a
total of more than 300 000 pounds has
gone to these factional groups the
oldest and best known is the European
research group instrumental in forcing
the EU referendum and known for toppling
Tory Prime Ministers famously fronted by
Jacob Reese mogg through the years of
parliament's brexit Chaos
now 36 different conservative MPS have
diverted public money to the ERG in this
Parliament alone but this group's
actually been around for a lot longer
since 2010 they've received nearly 400
000 pounds of your money all diverted by
MPS to support their work as the
staunchest brexiteers in Parliament in
this Parliament they've been overtaken
by a new faction the northern research
group a collection of Tory MPS from the
north of England led by ex-cabinet
Minister Jake Berry
it's been handed a hundred and forty
thousand pounds since the end of 2019
and here are the MPS who've diverted
their Public Funding into the group 41
of them in total each giving thousands
of pounds of their budget to one of the
factions in the conservative party now
we wanted to understand what they were
doing and why the public should be
funding it
to answer those questions we went to the
northern research group's Summer
Conference in Doncaster what the north
needs is bold conservances not socialism
NRG founder Jake Berry the most
important person in this room I asked
him what his group is really all about
the NRG was formed as a sort of Trade
union for Northern conservative MPS to
use our Collective muscle to campaign
for things like more investment in the
north to change government policy so it
favored things like education in the
north we've been supremely successful at
that can you just explain why public
money should be going into an
organization like this given what you do
well there are two parts of the northern
research group there's part of it which
is political because we are MPS and we
campaign and we campaign in our
constituency but the core function of it
is a shared services model for MPS which
is you say is publicly funded in the
same way the labor party has a similar
system it's publicly funded and that
only goes to support colleagues in their
parliamentary duties so it helps in
things like research tech savvy people
public money meant to fund research bit
of the MPS that sign up getting
something in return
looking closely at the data and a
striking pattern starts to emerge let's
look at one Northern research group MP
Matt Vickers he's the MP for Stockton
South now in mid-june 2021 he authorized
2 500 pounds from his office allowance
to go to the NRG
three weeks later he was the recipient
of a 2 500 pound campaign donation from
the northern Broadband provider IX
Wireless
this is conservative MP James Davies he
also diverted 2 500 pounds from his
office budget to the NRG in mid-june
just three days later he declared a
political donation for exactly the same
amount from the same company again IX
Wireless
overall MPS have diverted 139
000 pounds of public money to fund the
NRG well IX Wireless has given 134 000
pounds in campaigning cash towards NRG
members
24 MPS have all declared donations from
IX Wireless 22 of them have put some
public money towards funding the
northern research group
the origin of different sources of cash
really matters to MPS Public Funding is
tightly controlled but donations come
with far fewer restrictions and
importantly can be used to fund their
re-election campaign
one of the MPS that put money towards
the northern research group told me that
they knew that if they signed up to put
public funds towards the group then a
donation would follow not long after we
knew the money would come that's why
there was a deadline they said all of
this enough to trigger a formal
investigation
the independent parliamentary standards
Authority is the Watchdog for how
taxpayers money is spent in Parliament
we showed them what we'd uncovered and
they said in light of research by Sky
News ipsa has started an assurance
review to assess whether the NRG has
contravened the rules surrounding direct
payments of subscriptions from MP
business cost budgets ipsa will also
conduct Assurance reviews of the other
new Pool Services
this means a watchdog review into all
the new research groups and big
questions for the NRG if you look at the
data the match between the money put in
the Public Funding and the donations
that are coming to the same MPS quite so
I'm not sure do you have a list of the
members of the NRG because I know you've
tried to use these figures before to say
there's something wrong look I actually
think you're doing a massive disservice
at Sky
trashing Northern businesses who want to
support Northern MPS it is completely I
don't know whether you're alleging some
sort of illegalities
yeah it is completely wrong when
businesses want to go out and support
Northern MPS who are transforming the
business Community for them for those
businesses then to be trashed in the
media for doing something completely
legal and straightforward and I actually
think if we want to live in a country
where we celebrate business trashing
them for supporting political parties is
is a completely counterproductive thing
to do we're not trashing we're just
asking whether it's whether it's a
normal David Mundell who's a Scottish MP
kind of rooted 2500 pounds of his office
allowance to the nrj NRG two days later
he gets 2 500 pounds in a donation from
Ike's well people just look at that and
and and and find it odd can you just
explain what's going on there there's no
as I said there is no connection between
your membership and receiving political
donations overseas
experts suggest the time has come to
review the whole system of public
funding for research this method of
funding political research has been
around for many years what's changed I
think in the last Parliament is the
scale at which the public funds are
being used to fund specific interest
groups particularly on the conservative
side because the conservatives have been
in government and I think what this
really useful work from sky has revealed
is that there's an issue here that the
regulator which is ipser in this case
needs to I think have a think about the
circumstances have changed it's
appropriate to take a step back to say
is this how public the funds should be
being used and for MPS to have a chance
to take a view on that
today how your money moves through our
political system tomorrow Sky News
Westminster accounts investigation
reveals the thousands of hours MPS spend
working in second jobs